ah
Walter
hey wastelanders I'm your irradiated
host Dave and I'm here to tell you all
about GameSpot's fallout mod of the week
this week we're getting our hands on
something a little bit old-school tricky
veins crossbows of the Commonwealth this
mod adds something a little medieval to
your waistline arsenal in the form of
your very own customizable bolt slinging
crossbow fully featured with the ability
to change the bow itself the stock the
sights strength of the strings and even
choosing between armor-piercing and
flaming bolts to allow you to alter this
middle-aged piece of tech to suit your
specific needs
bolts will actually act like arrows
meaning they will have a travel time and
protrude from your foes like a humanoid
pincushion
it's rather satisfying to nail a member
of the filthiest Raider gang in the eye
with a well fired bolt and then also
have the ability to retrieve your
precious ammunition from the face of
said Raider
the crossbow has been balanced to be
both a versatile weapon in the early
levels as well as late into the game as
is a silenced weapon you can take
advantage of using the Sandman perk
which gives silent weapons a healthy
damage boost and as it's a rifle type
weapon the rifleman perk will increase
its damage even further the bolts from
this weapon do however seem to appear
from thin air during the reload
animation but the mod Creator has stated
that this is due to the weapon being
built using the reload animation from
the laser musket and besides this is a
game universe where mutant dogs roam the
streets and brains are kept alive inside
robots so I'm sure we can overlook the
odd crossbow bolt raking the laws of
physics this weapon fits perfectly into
the world of Fallout and adds a
wonderful dose of variety to those
brutish loud and uncivilized weapons
that most likely make up the rest of the
inventory the montt creator is also
planning on expanding the mod to have
more detailed textures a new type of bow
and even serrated poison shock explosive
and 44 caliber encased bolts so if
you've been looking for a piece of gear
to tie together your stealthy
wastelander and love the idea of
flinging deadly bolts with the shadows
this might just be the mod for you if
you use this mod we would love to hear
your thoughts on it and if you have any
mods you'd like to see feature in the
show then leave them in the comment
section below or tweet them at us using
the hashtag GS fallout
I've been Dave your common wealth guide
and until next week when we have another
episode and another mod stay safe out
there wasteland err